it has happened Donald J Trump has been
inaugurated and sworn in on a Bible
wasn't clear if it would be the Bible or
art of the deal that he swears in on his
two favorite books he is now president
Donald J Trump let's take a look at the
magical moment earlier today please
raise your right hand and repeat after
me I Donald John Trump do solemnly swear
I Donald John Trump do solemnly swear
that I will faithfully execute that I
will faithfully execute the office of
President of the United States the
office of President of the United States
and will to the best of my ability and
will to the best of my ability preserve
protect and defend preserve protect and
defend the Constitution of the United
States the Constitution of the United
States so help me God so help me God
congratulations mr. president
[Music]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
so now it begins he's the president now
he has a Republican House he has a
Republican Senate let's see what
executive orders he signs into law now
of course critical of President Obama
for using too many executive orders but
I'm sure there will be some reason why
he needed to use executive orders
probably to undo bad things that
President Obama did will he make America
great again and the funny thing about
make America great again is in the next
four years if he wants to be reelected
he needs to make America greater enough
that he justifies re-election but not so
great that the work is done because you
need to still be able to make the case
that there is more greatness to make I
guess in the following four years and I
already was mixing it up on Twitter i'm
on twitter at d pakman with some
trumpets and i said to them that they
said we're ready now he's the president
it's time to make America great again
and I asked can any trumpets or Trump
ians I'm kind of liking Trump Ian more
lately can any Trump Ian's tell me when
do you think the making great again of
America will be noticeable let's
question one and number two how will you
know what metrics will you use and it
nobody could actually tell me how they
were going to determine if Trump made
America great again one person talked
about unemployment and I said okay so we
have four point seven percent
unemployment what number would you like
to see to confirm that America has
gotten great again which of course
presumes that it's not right now and it
just exploded into labor force
participation conspiracies that have
been completely debunked all sorts of
stuff stock market what will you look at
that will you look at wages and the the
issue is and what became abundantly
clear based on the Trump Ian
again a group that was engaging with me
on Twitter earlier today is that the
numbers don't matter and they can't
matter because any measurable economic
indicator right now is looking pretty
good particularly compared to the state
in January of 2009 when now former
President Barack Obama took over so
unless anybody shows me otherwise the
numbers aren't going to matter the
numbers are not going to you whatever
happens in the next four years and we're
going to be tracking it here are the
numbers under Bush here are the numbers
under Obama and here is a president
Trump to date the numbers will be
explained away by the trumpets because
clearly as we've known throughout the
entire campaign this whole concept of
making America great again it's not
measurable it's just something you kind
of feel and that's why the role of
independent media is going to be so
important I hope that some corporate
media you know maybe Trump angered CNN
enough would the entire fake news thing
that CNN will hold Trump remotely
accountable for what he does but I'm not
counting on particularly the corporate
media and the establishment media that
is feeling very empowered by the
election of Trump to actually keep them
accountable so in the comments tell me
what measures will you look at to tell
you whether Trump has made America great
again it has to be measurable somehow
otherwise how would you know if you
should vote for him for re-election